[Music]
this week in our special series the work
shift we're looking at how our lives at
work have changed during the pandemic
with so many students learning remotely
last school year the burden of child
care fell mostly on mothers eighty
percent of americans who left the labor
force in september last year were women
now there's a renewed focus on child
care as many people get ready to head
back to the office adriana diaz who is
about to become a new mom shows us how
one e-commerce company in virginia with
a creative solution
at the offices of latched mama a
maternity and nursing clothes company
you're so helpful
it's byob
bring your own baby floor snacks are a
thing is that okay
here moms multitask as their babies lap
it up through naps in the warehouse
and just about everywhere she's an
independent worker yes she thinks that
she's she's getting stuff done she's got
her own little station and there she
goes
i have to say we've been sitting here
for a while and it's been very quiet
yeah
i thought i'd be hearing the babies more
when you keep mothers and babies close
that first year you don't hear a lot of
it what's wrong melissa word once a
stay-at-home mom built this
multi-million dollar brand that way
bringing in four of her children to work
when they were young something she plans
to do again you're pregnant absolutely
and this is your number six number six i
don't know if we would have six kids
come on let's go if it wasn't for
latch mama and the flexibility the
flexibility to bring your child to work
while their babies are toddlers a work
benefit she implemented in 2016. the
amount of people that told me that it
was a horrible idea when we started to
allow babies in the workplace like
horrible and i looked at all of them and
i shrugged my shoulders and i said we're
going to try and see what happens what
happened is her company was a success
growing an average of 86 percent each
year with 25 of her employees coming to
work with babies in tow the moms that do
bring their babies to work there's a
different sense of work ethic it's not
going to work everywhere we're not as
efficient with the babies here so you
can tell that absolutely but i think
when women get to be mothers first
you're gonna get those hours back
so let's say somebody brings their child
to work and it's just not going well
normally they have the flexibility to
say time out i'm gonna head home
and i'm 100 sure that baby is going to
get put to bed that night and i'm going
to have an email from them catching up
on that day's work are you concerned
about safety and liability there's a
waiver that's signed there's liability
insurance but truly it comes down to
trusting your employees hi boys like
warehouse manager amanda oberles who
works alongside her 18 month old griffin
he's a part of the team does it feel
that way it does feel that way is he our
best employee no
no he is not but she's grateful she
doesn't have to leave him a lot of
working moms talk about guilt do you
think that being able to bring your kid
to work the way you do might reduce that
at all it definitely reduces a lot of my
guilt i still feel a little bit of the
guilt because he doesn't get 100 of my
attention mom guilt's everywhere some
other companies from coast to coast have
similar policies like software
development firm tilda and the organic
skin care brand badger before kovid both
allowed babies up to six months old and
at least six state governments also let
workers bring in babies before the
pandemic
this spring almost a quarter of women
business owners said that the lack of
reliable child care made it harder to
hire according to a survey by payroll
provider gusto so nearly three-quarters
of those employers adopted
family-friendly policies like work from
home we have to acknowledge the fact
that things change after a baby's born a
woman changes
you're reborn hate to tell you you're
going to be a completely different
person on the other side really so scary
we don't talk about it
she hopes the work world after covid can
invest more in supporting new mothers we
can't see women as weaker on the other
side of childbirth or less capable we
need to see them as more capable for cbs
this morning adriana diaz midlothian
virginia
i would not have thought that would have
worked i have to say i really wouldn't
all the little kids running around but
you see it and it clearly is working it
reminds me before you have a baby when
you get on a plane and the baby's
screaming you're like
but after you have your own baby it
doesn't need to bother you it really
doesn't you're like i understand it's
okay yeah and the relief from the mom
guilt and by the way dad guilt is a
thing too but being able to bring your
work life and your personal life
together is a wonderful thing and relief
i wonder how many notes adriana took she
probably took well
shawna was saying cut to adriana having
six children of her own just like that
adriana you heard us